james contó el número de cocodrilos en
varios cuerpos de aguas locales y
gráficos los resultados cuántos
cocodrilos - hay en el pantano mordedura
comparado con el lago asesinos y el
arroyo reptil juntos
bien y aquí abajo tenemos esta gráfica
de barras que james construyó de alguna
forma sobreviviendo al viaje a todos
estos lugares y contando cocodrilos al
menos espero que haya estado detrás de
una reja o algo similar
pero bueno regresemos lo que nos piden
es cuántos cocodrilos - hay en el
pantano mordedura comparado con el lago
asesinos y el arroyo reptil juntos
entonces primero necesitamos saber
cuántos cocodrilos hay en el lago
asesinos y el arroyo reptil juntos para
que con ese número veamos cuántos
cocodrilos - hay en el pantano
mordeduras bien pues veamos aquí abajo y
por aquí tenemos
agua asesinos el agua asesinos está
justo por aquí y esto suena muy bien
seguro y bastante peligroso pero
observan que su línea en esta barra
marca el valor de 6 así que hay seis
cocodrilos en el lago asesinos ya esto
hay que sumarle porque vamos a combinar
la cantidad de cocodrilos en el agua
asesinos y en el arroyo reptil así que
si nos fijamos en el arroyo reptil que
está justo aquí podemos ver que su barra
nos da este valor que es de nueve
entonces su línea de barra nos da el
valor de nueve y por eso vamos a tomar
la suma de 6 más 99 podridos hay en el
arroyo reptil y bueno 69 podemos
descomponer el 6 para hacer esta suma
más fácil vamos a descomponer al 6 en 5
y 1 y entonces tengo que 6 más 9 es lo
mismo que
9 1 que es 10 + 5 que es 15 15 entonces
hay un total de 15 cocodrilos en el lago
asesinos y el arroyo reptil juntos y
ahora si podemos ver cuántos pocos dedos
de - tenemos con el pantano mordedura
que tenemos justo aquí observa el
pantano mordedura este de aquí tienen
una línea hasta arriba en la barra que
nos da el valor de 12 entonces hay 12
cocodrilos en el pantano mordedura y
ahora si podemos ver cuántos cocodrilos
- hay de 12 que tiene el pantano
mordedura a 15 que hay en el lago
asesinos y el arroyo reptil juntos bueno
pues nos tomamos la resta de 15
ya esto le quitamos 12 cuanto menos hay
en 12 en 15 bueno si tenemos 15 y le
quitamos 12 eso me va a dar el valor de
3 así que hay tres cocodrilos menos en
el pantano mordedura comparado con el
lago asesinos y el arroyo reptil juntos